you're a cop and everything but name
saving Gotham's not my job anymore
you've never mentioned your mother
before she's going to kill me
your mom escaped hell if so she'll just
run right back like a good mom
I implore every citizen of Gotham find
fish Mooney to think I let that punk
live a mistake we both made you just
remember penguins eat fish
I faith in you in us
she gets her bearings there's no telling
what she'll do to get a revenge I want
an armor
on me like me
I do this there's no turning back no
there isn't
so much punishment so little time
you
hey youtubers is Charlie so Gotham
season 3 trailer let's break it down I'm
also gonna explain what's going on even
ounce like a couple really big
characters from the comics like Harley
Quinn or coming to the show
someone explain what's going on so a
couple of big takeaways from this
trailer you probably saw fish Mooney
she's back for better or worse that you
know depends on how much you liked her
character in season one but now she's
back she's a metahuman so they're just
doing more metahumans on the show that
was the whole idea with the end of last
season is that a bunch of them escaped
Arkham so I think that was just like a
story device for them to be able to
crank up the craziness on the show which
i think is a good move for them like
it's always more fun when you focus on
the villains but the real king of Gotham
like they kind of been teasing is Jim
Gordon this season so I'm hoping we get
to see a lot of him and bullet because
Bullock kind of balances his Tona like
Ben McKenzie does a really good job of
doing like the intense Jim Gordon the
really serious version of the character
he doesn't do so well when he tries to
be super funny so usually you need
another character there to balance him
out he's like the straight man he's the
one that reacts to all the craziness
he's like I can't believe all this [ __ ]
is happening in Gotham would you look at
all these metahumans running around but
the other big news is that the Bruce
Wayne character is going to be
developing his kind of douchebag rich
preppy persona you know like when he's
driving around in Lambos with models
hanging off his arms he's going to be
figuring that out this season they said
he's going to cross the line and they're
doing court of owls so I imagine him
doing a lot of the rich boy stuff is
going to throw him into the world of the
court of owls those are the ruling rich
families of Gotham so naturally he'd be
out bumping into those people if he's
throwing money around so on top of that
Hugo Strange looks like he's behind bars
as is the Riddler who will both be
moving closer to their comic book
personas the Riddler was teasing that he
might get really close to the comic book
costume this season so he's already had
some classic Riddler moments now he's
just going to get closer to doing that
all the time
so the other big news that a lot of you
are asking about is poison ivy they had
a really young version of her that was
hanging out with Catwoman but now
they've recast the role and it's like
this really sexy older actress so if you
remember Pamela Isley from the animated
series imagine her being more like that
I don't remember if they said that she's
a metahuman already or if we're gonna
see her get her powers but seeing a
character get their powers from the
comics is always a lot of fun so I don't
think that they would deny us that so I
think we'll get to see that play out
over the course of the season so that'll
be interesting but I'll be curious to
see
see how they explain the recasting and
on top of that they announced that
they're doing Harley Quinn and Killer
Croc in a future season not this season
but in a future season so in like season
four season five they'll be able to do
Gotham City sirens you can kind of see
the problem when they started the series
they started out with like a really
young Bruce Wayne in a really young
Catwoman so they're both aging up like
young actors aged up very fast it's a
big problem for TV shows but it actually
works in Gotham's favor because you want
these two characters to age up to the
point where they can be their fully
actualized comic book selves you want a
version of Bruce Wayne that looks like
he could put the cape and cowl on so you
want him to grow up as fast as possible
and you want Catwoman to keep pace with
that so that they can do some of the
more fun relationship e-type things you
can't really do that with young actors
but you get a little bit older they can
get into all kinds of fun trouble
together so definitely looking forward
to that I was at you know like last
season I wasn't super creatively
satisfied with Gotham I kind of dropped
to in-video just because it wasn't
really fun anymore but anything can
shoot like any number of changes could
turn that any other direction
there's so many shows like even
Supergirl was kind of like that during
season one so now that that's on the CW
they made a bunch of creative changes
behind the scenes it's going to be way
more badass like their doing Superman
and you know and this is a Gotham video
talking about Batman stuff there's a
rumor that Supergirl season 2 is doing
bat woman that's unconfirmed so I'm not
gonna hold my breath but they're doing
bat woman's girlfriend from the comics
she's already on the show so it makes
sense that they would bring her in so
they could do birds of prey so it seems
like Gotham's working up to Gotham City
sirens with poison ivy Harley Quinn and
Catwoman and we might see birds of prey
on Supergirl season 2 so all things
being equal though I do feel like they
will be able to use the cape and cowl
eventually just because if Superman was
previously off-limits for TV now the TV
shows are totally doing Superman they
can probably open the door for Batman on
Gotham but I think that's a lot further
off so let me know in the comments what
do you guys think about sexy poison ivy
and Harley Quinn coming on Gotham I have
no idea who they would cast but I
imagine that they would cast someone of
the similar age to poison ivy someone
who's a little bit older than the actors
playing Bruce and selina kyle and for
those of you that are asking I don't
know if I'm gonna be doing videos for
Gotham season 3 I'm probably not going
to be doing week-to-week videos but I
totally do a video
know when they do something really
really big so there will be a couple of
Gotham videos this season but probably
not week to week but if you guys didn't
know there's a bunch of other stuff
happening this week they're going to be
dropping a whole bunch of flash arrow
Supergirl season 2 Justice Society news
pretty soon there's going to be a new
Star Wars trailer so be sure to
subscribe to get everything there's
already been a bunch of news for some of
the other shows too so I'll try to get
that out as fast as possible so while
you guys wait for all that stuff to post
you can click here for my Luke Cage
trailer video that's coming real soon
and you can click here to learn all
about the next Superman movie that
they're planning at Warner Brothers so
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
you